africa was viewed as
a land of problems
requiring
support
assistance
from outside
now
the change happening is that
africa is the land of opportunity
for business
because
that is where the future demographic
demographics of the world are these
world populations are growing strongly
they're much younger more balanced
that's why the iet revolution is having
the biggest impact
in terms of delivery of services in
terms of reducing the cost of doing
business
so i do believe that the narrative about
africa of the past
is still stuck
in some people's mind
but the reality is that
africa has changed dramatically over the
last decade
now there are threats
emanating from the global economy
there are also threats emanating from
internal tensions
around the
issues
inequality
inclusion and so on
there are issues related to slow
transformation
and those are the challenges we must
confront now
but
the image of africa is the land of
opportunity in business
where africa's risk is the same as latin
america
or asia is the one which is now
gradually
sinking people's minds it has taken time
but it is the right time